yeah and when welcome to this video it's
a bit late
Mabel it didn't move so I stopped the
recording and I mean like waiting is
kind of not very entertaining so let's
not be too good here okay Bishop g5
first of course so I'm giving I'm given
a slight head start here and there are
some funny lines there with Knight takes
e4 yeah I can I can do this at it it's
kind of useful in most cases anyway not
sure but okay what is he going to play
Queen eight would be the most usual
movie em I know I chose them
now let's put this back it doesn't make
much sense anymore
okay so just rinse it une soupe
everything under control and prepare
before I mean if it takes a tool that at
least took a long time but it probably
likes this nylon f4
yeah I think I go for this this is some
taking he is always kind of difficult
decision but I get excellent control
over you for now so it's something that
also quite important I can't have to
kick this light I don't know check
making any sense okay just takes it so
I've got two lights here against two
bishops 13 d6 here which is completely
not probably am it didn't have much
against it anyway but let's do that now
is a very nice position I can um yeah I
can simply take I can also play this
move where's the Queen going let's wait
for meeeeee let's think for a moment I
can also do this that's probably not bad
just keeping complete control
[Music]
yeah 95 is basically he almost has two
sec the Queen then I can just click here
look the force irritating me a little
bit but he cannot take the Queen let's
let's just calculate this a little bit
after this will is flex more
Queen takes Knight takes rook takes 97th
doesn't work at all so he has to go back
and now I can think of what I want to
take yeah I think just take this pawn
and yeah like it's desperate and need to
try to get something going but that
doesn't work we'll just take it 90 f6
now is possible already I think yeah and
now I can just take you 5 or Queeny form
but also is pretty strong yeah very
strong so I can take with the rook or
with the knight who takes us actually
better yeah we age six yeah okay yeah
that's probably clean enough check
check
black resigns okay so dad I think g5 is
not a good move I think that was the
beginning of blacks issues I mean here
this is certainly okay but this is not
good Jam yeah the engine agrees with the
capture here
and here I'm gaining full control over
you form doesn't look right and b6 I
don't know it's a slow yeah
and here I mean it's it looks very
critical already but I think the moment
i get d six and it's basically calling
now I can take b6 e already but that
this cannot be bad now nights can be
strong here they're definitely on Jackie
yeah Karrueche six and that F six also
strong but there are many ways to do it
the other mean the main issue really was
this g5 move check another moment he
goes g5 he gives up on the idea to
recapture on air five with a pawn so
after I'm I'm clearing out the defenders
of before I now i have 3 pieces
potentially competing for uniform and he
has the bishop on g7 which is dead so
that is a really good position for white
okay guys thanks for watching